foreign
[Music]
how prevalent fentanyl was and that was
the conversations we had toward the end
over and over was just how could you do
this when you know that it's in all of
these drugs and so that's the insanity
of addiction right Duffy knew from his
job how dangerous this was but he
thought he had it under control
[Music]
it's like you want a smile
Duffy was introduced to drugs when he
was in high school he hurt his back and
had an injury that led to him being
prescribed Oxycontin and the progression
of the disease of addiction especially
with opiates is that it's too expensive
to maintain that and they don't even
realize they're addicted until they
start getting dope sick and they end up
going to something that's cheaper that
they have access to so people will go to
heroin but that's really where it
started for Duffy and he struggled with
it for many years
so Duffy and I met
and started dating pretty quickly we
were together three and a half years we
met in recovery
and we built a life together we
got our own place we had our son we were
super grateful for everything that we
built because we've been through so many
ups and downs and lows in our lives
Duffy had a few periods of sobriety one
was for four years and then he relapsed
and then got sober before I met him so
he had about a year when we started
dating
and then he relapsed about
a year and a half into our relationship
I was definitely aware that Duffy was
struggling he was very depressed he had
some seasonal depression going on we
were both working really hard he was
working two jobs I was working a new job
many hours having a toddler and then my
dad was sick and ultimately passed away
in December of 2020 and so that winter
is when things really started to unravel
for him
and he tried to get in with therapists
and he didn't connect with her she was
very inexperienced he stopped going
didn't continue and
it eventually led to him going back to
drugs and
he tried to stop and he wanted to stop
but he couldn't he would put together a
little bit of sobriety time and then
relapse again and it was just it wasn't
pretty
Duffy's job was a peer support
specialist
so what that looks like is somebody
comes into the emergency room after a
drug overdose when somebody's been
narcaned and they meet with that person
and Duffy met with those people who
overdosed and speak from his experience
as somebody in recovery to say I've been
where you are over and over and over
again and that was what would get people
to want to get help and so I mean he
saved people's lives and
I was so proud of him and he was so
amazed to be able to do that as a job
with everything he'd been through and
turned his pain into a purpose and
that's the insanity of addiction right
Duffy knew from his job how dangerous
this was but he thought he had it under
control
and the last day that I saw him we were
in an argument about him going to
treatment
and he thought he might lose his job he
was fearful to reach out and admit that
he had been using and get help you know
the stigma even for people in recovery
is strong
and that was the last time I saw him
alive and
um he was going to come home he promised
he was going to come home and he got
drugs one more time and that was what
had the fentanyl in it that time and he
[Music]
was without oxygen for too long before
the ambulance got to him they couldn't
Narcan him because nobody had Narcan
around
and he had severe brain damage so he was
on life support for three days before
they actually declared him brain dead
Duffy's best friend also passed through
a fentanyl overdose six months after he
did and he was my son's Godfather so he
has gone through some emotional ups and
downs but now he's in a really good
position he's very happy and seems to be
on a better track but this is going to
be a lifelong thing so as he gets older
I'm going to
feel it out and see what makes sense but
I'm going to let him know that his dad
was sick
that he was heroic in his own way and
saved lives but that he struggled with
this illness and explained fentanyl to
him phenol is terrifying
it keeps me up at night it makes my
stomach turn
so I think we all need to know what
fentanyl is what it's in and educate the
people around us because it's a Public
Health crisis and we all need to carry
Narcan
and
the other part of it is the borders and
I don't want to make it
political but it's just a fact this is
coming in over the borders and the
Border policies of failing
addiction doesn't discriminate it
doesn't have a face it is everybody
stems from trauma it stems from mental
health issues it stems from Pain and so
to treat this as some type of moral
failing to me is mind-boggling when it's
really a medical issue it's not like we
grow up and say we want to become an
addict that was never something in my
life that I thought I would be
you can't make anybody get help you
can't save anybody you can't force them
to get treatment but you can love them
and encourage them
just love them through it as best you
can and I know that they'll make it
really hard to do that and I say that
from experience
[Music]